can sit on your lap now you can sit on
my lap all you want because I am a male
Santa and that is something that Phyllis
cannot do oh my God okay this is really
comfortable okay tell me what you want
little
boy I don't know I didn't know you were
going to ask me that what did you think
was going to happen I didn't know no
one's ever let me sit on their lap
before hurry up just say some
toys can can you give me some choices oh
my God Kevin please
sorry Coppa squat here we
go sorry Sor COA squat I'm glad what
would you like for Christmas little
Kevin I don't
know I didn't know you were going to ask
me that well what did you think was
going to happen
here
sorry
well you clearly don't care so why don't
you just leave I would like to stay this
pertains to me I would like you to leave
why don't you go outside and take a shot
of insulin and have a nap okay why do
you always assume I have diabetes you
have a glass of apple juice and tell me
that you don't have diabetes
okay all right see just the noise you
made when you stood up I
could
hey if Saber truly cared about a
long-term well-being they would set up
hand desanitizing stations hold up
what's a hand desanitizing station bowl
of dirt okay you
understand this is oh my
God that's a good improv okay you
understand the more we expose ourselves
to germs the stronger
aend the tale of swey
Todd he get
shoot I forgot
it there we
go look on your face was so funny I mean
I I I'm feeling that it's it's very full
so I don't think she's been releasing at
all you're definitely feeling
that the baby should grab on to that I
think she will she'll be good so like a
c very funny over there so just grab
onto it and I squeeze it that hard yeah
yeah that hard yeah really feel it it's
getting repetitive I think we got
it
what happened to forign three Michael
it's okay two minutes is too soon 5
minutes and 2 minutes is a very big
difference you got to hold it together
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
now I told you War me 5 minutes what
happened to 4 and three because 2
minutes doesn't do us any good come here
you got hold it together
okay this here
Plantation is running low on green BS um
we ain't got no money to pay the people
who sell us the sades and man I can't do
this
Michael
[Laughter]
basically Toby yeah could you write down
the name of that Rehabilitation Clinic
you mentioned
wow think
that's what does that even
say well hello
everybody hello everybody
oh man for I tried to do some research
once MOS and I rented a movie about a
Latina wedding planner with a big fat
ass moose and I rented a movie about a
Latino wedding planner with a big fat
ass I tried to do some research
once
no I know nothing about wedding planning
I tried to do some research once Mose
and I rented a movie about a Latina
wedding planner with
enormous this is what we did last time
here we go will the someone's fault well
no it's it's not it's not anybody's
fault you know what let's just look at
the lines and then we'll do the scene
again
thank you you're
welcome you're insane you are insane I
know you even get to any of our dialogue
great Phyllis did I or did I not say
fruit you did say fruit and what is that
cake and what did I say
fruit
sorry is this she thinks funny is this
funny to you
Phyllis she's nervous yeah well she
should be nervous because I'm about to
kick her
ass I'm going to walk in
again you don't really toss the Dome try
to destroy the old ways Gabe I will not
let you do
it don't make me pre-fire you you
wouldn't dare
oh man and when I get promoted you're
full fired if you get promoted
ah don't make me pre-fire you you
wouldn't dare you're pre-fired and when
I'm promoted you're full fired if you're
promoted oh it's just like the old days
the property you're looking at is in
great shape and equipment is 100%
pristine but you look at the
preservative
whoa whoa something major happened
wasn't my fault installed poorly
okay I know Bob Vance DWI shw I work
next door just give him a
call call Bob Vance call Bob
Vance Bob
just forget it Mr shrew are you looking
to preserve it as Munitions just I'll
call you
back oh my
God you want to go today I can't giv him
blood so wow good for you good for you
how often can you actually donate blood
is there a limit I don't I thought there
was well your body only has a certain
[Laughter]
amount can you hear me what what I can
hear you why are you calling me my
minutes don't roll over I have to use
them today
okay there's a press release that Ryan
would like I can hardly hear
you
makush he's watching million-dollar
baby he's going to try to kill
me
it uh I know I used to be a temp here
and now I'm your boss and I understand
how that must be weird for you but
you I'm really sorry I broke that was
too
good well I'd do the scene but BJ's not
here and
resetting here when I roll where PJ go I
guess what surround sound means is that
right over here
CH two
speakers damn we have two
speakers what honey oh Jesus this is
terrible we'll never finish this episode
um check this out
folds the
wall
sorry oh my do you want your life to be
better or worse or to stay the same get
out of my
way
Danny look at
[Laughter]
me sorry
sorry
sorry sorry totally fine
hey
Dwight we have three sex or or heavy
petting closets one masturbation closet
does anyone have a problem with that yes
gay closet five that was five closet
that's that that wasn't the problem
three heavy petting closets one
masturbation closet and one gay closet
absolutely I problem everybody happy the
glory
what well I heard about it holy fth
closet will have a glory
hole here's your
headline Scranton Paper Company Dunder
Mifflin apologizes to valued client some
companies still know how business is
done more like the whole
article over the gums and through the
lips
look out
stomach there we
go my uncle Harvey shro is a fudge
packer he works at the Hershey
factory now I know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but you know what that is a risk
we have
to that
is that is a risk that we have to no no
no I know what you're saying why you
keep
going hey I know what you're thinking
won't that just
shed I know what you're thinking won't
that just shed more light on the penises
but that is a risk we need to take Pam
thank you Pam why don't you work with
palas and draw a picture of the
exposer don't you I want it on my desk
by the end of the day or you will
receive a full
disadulation what's that
love the way John cracks we had a
funeral for a
bird I'm pretty sure none of that's real
you're not
real
huh do we have any
muffins yeah take a longer pause before
you answer Pam I don't know if you like
music but I was thinking maybe one of
these days God Bless
America would you please sign my company
directory I'm about
people okay
good something like that the hell is
that I want to see his penis there it is
uh it is rumored that they will declare
I can't I can't see it um you don't know
your
lines I lost bankruptcy what are you
talking about yes Michael what is so
urgent David guess who I'm dressed up
sorry one more time you should have like
I do I have the lines right in front of
me I know I've painted them on the
inside of my
eyes had a curiosity do you have any
other characters oh I'm working on
Scranton
Strangler um
I'm going to get you what do you
think oh I'm working on a new one
Granton Strangler I'm going to kill
you oh I'm working on the Scranton
Strangler don't start laughing I'm
working I'm working on a new one
Scranton Strangler I'm kidding now you
now you with the Laing okay you know
what Jim I am taking you off this
account for unrelated Reon don't you
smirk at
me okay okay you know what Jim get your
tongue in your
face okay you know what Jim I am taking
you off this account for unrelated
reasons he was really close to you
really close he was really close just
let him flirt with her people meet each
other all sorts of way who are we to
stand in the way Pam you know he's not
going to get anywhere and you know he's
going to blow our sail who cares it's
not that huge a sale the
Schwab bam you know he's not going to
get anywhere and you know he's going to
blow our sale who cares it's not that
huge a sale the Schwab guy tell
us this here is a raon test kit okay
I'll be putting them everywhere and
please don't throw these
out this is a raidon test
kit please don't throw these
out see them all over the office
[Laughter]
is there anything you need from me I'd
like to go back to bed yeah Joe just get
some rest to see you Monday unless
you're still
sick um all right we'll have a great
long weekend I'll probably be just
[Laughter]
sleep you enjoyed that didn't
you
going to have kids and I'm going to get
married not necessarily in that order
and they going to live here
[Laughter]
what I love you I love you Michael I
love you too what are you even talking
about I was just talking about I
farted are you kidding me I did oh my
God this is this is my place okay let's
go back to one hello Michael how are you
good how are you good to you see o sorry
there okay well why don't we just step
in
what he'd enjoy to be fired I don't
think he would tell him that I am far
too valuable to
[Laughter]
you fire
who I I what who was he saying I can't
really make it out
fire quiet you you know what those are
grounds Michael look at
[Music]
me hey J hey what's up hey um I know
it's last minute but I was
wondering
what hey hey um I know it's last minute
but I was wondering if it would
be that was you I was wondering if it
would be
cool I didn't do
anything I was wondering if it would be
cool if I brought my oh my God wait it's
casual so I'm not really worried about
numbers or anything cool all right
thanks nobody even signed my birthday
poster probably because it doesn't even
look like me it's from last year no
[Laughter]
you're making it
worth so see I will end up having your
little butt in jail and what they will
do to you is nothing compared to what
I'll do to you before you get down there
you are not to be
ready he said I was dull
I'm
not he said I was
dull think you have to admit you flipped
out a little bit I think you should stop
talking
now I just want she's still a little
sore are you sitting on your donut
on I think that she's just a little sore
still you have a your donut h
who is
it who is it
Michael
hi you say
hi he did he said
hi what's your blood type oh negative
universal donor universal donor
mhm
you have to have sex with a woman then
sex with a man and then just compare the
two preferably been the same night would
you consider nope taking that bullet for
me
no how do we figure this out well you
just have to sleep with a woman I can do
that then sleep with a man and then just
compare when you think about
both
when are you free
[Laughter]
sorry yep still breathing Jim I said not
till she's older
okay just a few of the pranks we do here
we finally have a prank we have a
prank